I've opened up devtools and I've
navigated to the network tab I'm ready
to record so i will refresh the page you
can see the three requests for the three
different images horse one horse two and
horse three it looks like their sizes
are really different notice how horse to
is almost ten times bigger than horse
one and horse three is also bigger than
horse one given that the images look
identical it seems like there could be
some wasted bytes here inside the
elements pane I can find out the actual
dimensions of these three images there
are a couple ways of doing it I'm going
to show you a hard way and then an easy
way dev tools has this awesome feature
where you can manipulate an element in
the Dom by clicking on it up here so
I've clicked on the first horse and then
inside the console I can access it by
typing dollar sign zero when i press
enter you see that hey it's the horse to
find out the horses actual width i'll
simply access the property natural width
all right so it looks like that one it
is for 26 i'll select horse too and now
because horse 2 is selected I can
actually run the exact same command it
looks like that one is also 426 pixels
wide so i'll try the third one and aha
that one is twice as large at 852 pixels
so it looks like these three images have
different sizes okay now here's the easy
way of figuring that out simply hover
over the image and you can see it right
here there's the natural width and
height horse 2 is the same just like we
saw a second ago and then horse 3 is
twice as large so then what could be
different about horse one and horse too
as it turns out there compression levels
are different so at this point it's
clear that horse 3 is definitely a
larger image but then what's different
about horse one and horse too if they
have the same resolution but different
sizes well then it's pretty clear that
they have different compression levels
so the answer to this quiz is that they
have different compression levels and
different resolutions